Kelly it's just because
Asian guys remind me of my brother what
the and that's why
what
you don't date Asian guys
um I've never known really
interesting yeah interesting interesting
yeah interesting yeah yeah oh [__]
interesting hey
that's what it felt like it was like two
colonizers konichiwa can I eat some
sushi after a [__]
why don't you like Asian guys
um are you are you a race Trader are you
a race Trader no like you wouldn't even
date a Vietnamese guy
um no not really I actually like I just
I don't know they just come off like I
get so close like they're just my
friends like they give me like my
brother like
they remind me so much I think we need
to ban the word like
some of these people like why like why
would you like I feel like like I feel
like my friends like friends they remind
me to like my like my brother you know
what life is
like is the new um
that's what it is
before people was like well um I I gotta
um do um so so when people do that
it's really just to replace the the
thought is not made so they just replace
all that with that word like you know
like could do shut the [__] up
take a pause
which is equal which is equal to
shutting the [__] up
reflect shut it the [__] up
it was like a good time to just pause it
back let me think about what I'm going
to say before right
they remind me so much like the way that
they like they carry themselves they
remind me so much of my brother that
it's like sorry go ahead continue okay
music it's her dating preferences it's
your business don't care
don't care
you should be free to date whoever you
want to date for whatever reason you
want to date them but saying Asian men
remind you of your brother is one of the
most biggest cop-outs in one of the
dumbest things I've ever heard it
insinuates the idea that all Asian men
are alike
irrespective of heights
skin tone
personality upbringing class but every
single one of them reminds you of your
brother that is stupid that's right that
is what that is incredibly [__] dumb
she can't be right she's saying my bad
not bad listen it's just one of those
things where I'm like just have your
preference and just say I don't want to
talk about it but don't get some goofy
[__] why you don't do black women I
don't want to date black women because
criminality you know what am I
insinuating that's what it sounds like
you imagine if a brother just popped out
the closet like Whitney Houston
um every
[Laughter]
I'm every Asian
tops things in Asian bun baby
just don't do it bro just did what you
want to do it bro but don't come out
here and say this goofy [__] because
that stuff that's when you start to make
terrible stereotypes about whatever
group you're talking about
I have like a brotherly relationship
with myself with most Asian men that I
that I meet wait can you scoot your um
your chair into the table so we can get
you a little bit of posture uh can you
just put that mic closer put it in your
mouth now use a bit of tongue yeah yeah
yeah hey yeah
whenever I meet a girl she can do that
sound effect I don't know why I'm like
yay
anyways
I'm like damn how are you so good at
this
big announcement we're going on tour
what yes we're on tour what are you
gonna do we're gonna react to videos
live no we're gonna do stand up crack
jokes maybe laugh maybe you don't but
you're gonna pay 75 to find out
so
I mean make sure you guys click the link
in the description I think the first
couple days we're doing Detroit we're
going to be doing Washington Pittsburgh
and Washington so those are the three
C's we're doing this late summer end of
August and then after that we're gonna
be doing the rest of America we're
likely going to go to Europe some parts
we're excited to get to catch you guys
face to face
I can't describe it they remind you of
yeah like they have the same personality
traits as like the uh
that's a bit you know I don't know are
you saying all Asian men are the same
yeah I'm the ones that I've met I'll
remind you of how your brother acts most
yes the ones that I have met yes or like
one of my cousins or something I don't
know it's just like
what about like a nice Filipino boy yeah
there's a I've met like I've met a lot
of them yeah I just blouse what about
allows a guy from Laos
maybe like American Born but Asians she
said yeah she said I don't know why
there's one good name one all of them
like let me name I don't all of them I
know Asia I know Asia so Laos no
Cambodia okay uh Malaysia Filipino uh
Japanese Korean what about a month how
about North Koreans they're built
different literally starving and [__]
come on no Chinese no Mongolian huh no
Kazakh they're kind of Asian but also
kind of roasted no definitely it sounds
like not Vietnamese because your
brother's Vietnamese so that's like yeah
Vietnamese like I don't know it's just
like we we're too alike to like you know
like I'm I can I can relate to you so
much that I can't learn anything so it's
like Mongolian
oh my God I'm gonna have to skip this
guy too Korean Japanese Chinese oh my
God yes he did it he actually did it
I think this guy's more autistic than
that oh my God
[__] did that he
now I know my ab yeah you don't shut the
[__] up okay what about um
I'm running out of Asian s
Thai uh I've met no I only know one time
Indonesian
like Filipino okay guys I gotta skip
this part this is yes a few moments
later I'm missing like at least one or
two of the South he's still going oh my
God let me skip again much much later oh
I miss Taiwan thank you
it sounds like all right
your race I'm not
I know the differences
that's what it sounds like are you just
not attracted to Asian men yeah I would
say that to him [__] that's what
she said flashback guys
um
I've never known and a flashback I took
you five minutes okay you're triggered
no no no no no after five minutes ago I
know I know I was there she went I'm not
into Asian men and they went what about
Laos Taiwan Mongolia Japan Korea not
South North China
Malaysia Indonesia
no
okay five minutes later so now I've like
listed all the Asian countries can I
just ask are you just not into Asian men
triggered [__]
trigger it's okay
that was one of the dumbest things I've
ever seen in a long time it took you
five minutes to just realize after she'd
already said it three times like come on
bro I think this guy's been on the
Spectrum not gonna lie
and then like I said it's just a thing
like we're just so like like I like
learning from my from my man like I like
learning about I like learning about
different culture too and like I like
just experiencing new things but it's
like with somebody if I was dating like
a Vietnamese guy we relate so much did
you speak Vietnamese um I understand it
but I don't speak okay wait so
you you would relate too much to them
and that's
I know it sounds weird it's just like
it's just like I can't I can't live I
can't learn from you or I can't you
can't teach you can't really like teach
me new things about or you can learn the
language
sorry sorry
oh sorry carry on they sound like you
don't know [__] about your own culture
just carry on listen okay before I just
even continue because she's not really
saying much it just sounds like some
self-loathing like there's some parts of
Asian culture that she really doesn't
like or her own culture and that it when
she sees other Asian men those feelings
come out that's what it sounds like
that's what it sounds like generally
speaking she thinks she can't learn
anything how can you ever know that
without ever dating them it don't even
sound like you're ever that deep of a
cult like connection to the Homeland
like you can always be the language
you know what I mean you grew tell me
you ain't you ain't even been around a
lot of Asian people then you say I know
I know a lot of guys from Vietnam
Vietnam or whatever so I don't know you
say a bunch of confusing stuff but all
of this
just sound like
you dislike either being Vietnamese or
you just dislike Vietnamese men that's
it
about I care about he if he cares about
my culture and he wants to learn more
about my culture and my boyfriend right
now he's black
surprised you are super okay okay me too
I looked at him like she looked like she
dates black kids
there's another lie
and he he goes to extremes to try to
teach me more about Black Culture and he
tries to make me help me understand it
better so that I have a better
understanding of him just out of
curiosity
um
he's very like he's very very he's on
rallies he's LED rallies before he's LED
protests like he's very like passionate
about his culture which is which was why
I would say it's unfair of me to
disregard it and not want to learn about
it more because if he cares about it so
much why why shouldn't why should I make
him feel like I don't care about it
well I mean I think it's great that you
want to learn about his his culture I
just in terms of an attraction trigger
I've never heard someone say learning
about like it would
I would not be attracted to someone if I
if I could not learn from their culture
and if that's the case for you hey
that's that's totally fine but
yeah I don't know it's not not just like
just the culture thing it's just a
learning like learning a period like
yeah you know what it sounds like
you know what it sounds like
it sounds like I only date black people
with a lot of steps that's what it
sounds like Maybe not maybe that's just
the real life my idea why do that sounds
like she got a problem with her own
culture and she'd rather just be
anywhere else
maybe maybe something to learn from her
dad maybe something learned from there
but I'll just talk about all Asian men
remind me of my brothers really stupid
I'm sorry just that this is so uh
reductive in how you talk about Asian
people in general it makes them sound
singular in personality type or anything
first off she said all Asian men that's
crazy because you best believe
culturally speaking Japanese are
distinctly different than Koreans
they're sickly different from people
from Malaysia in terms of climate in
terms of Lifestyle in terms of many
other things it's like when people talk
about Africa it's like yeah
the temperament in Ethiopia is going to
be distinctly different than the
temperament in Rwanda even though
they're neighboring countries same thing
for Somalia or I go all the West Africa
it's just stupid when you do that
Europeans are not all the same sorry
somebody in Italy is not going to live
the same as somebody in Northern UK
that's just not going to happen
depending on where in Italy as well
because it depends where true south
south of Italy is completely different
than the North ah it's just it's weird
when I hear goofy stuff like this I'm
like hey you got some [__] to figure out
but you saying this [__] like no
that's something that I think it's okay
for people to be like I ain't rocking
with that I don't like it when people
say oh you know all white people are the
same it's like what is the same to me
what's that even really me
you date one right person they all
remind you the same white person that's
weird you know
is that crazy
I've seen that I heard that I have heard
it too I just every time I hear it I
think yes it's kind of weird yeah it is
kind of weird I don't know where it
really is from whatever no there's no
traumas and stuff like that and stuff
like that could be different for a lot
of people but I've heard that rhetoric a
lot
I heard that
from men from women about their own
culture and they're like um
no yeah no whoever because we're in this
country I've heard that from the most
white girls doing playing I don't want
to date a white boy
I've heard that more much more here no
yeah also I'm from long gay so yeah
I I I think that a lot of people no no I
think a lot of people grow up and they
just don't find themselves or their
family cool or interesting and so they
consume other cultures through media and
find that stuff more engaging and more
socially appealing and so they find like
a bit of revulsion towards their own
culture and start to fetishize and take
a serious interest in others right so I
will Don play like oh America and then
they'll obsess over Japanese culture you
know they've never been or anything like
that they turn into weebs who dress like
Japanese people and because konnichiwa
and say all this goofy [__] I I suspect
it just comes from
young age but I could be wrong so just
take my [__] for two yeah they don't
think their culture is appealing and the
parts that are appealing to others they
don't want to associate with that yeah
and then the Europe there's some other
thing so they think about rejecting it
it's gonna just make them seem more cool
and more interesting or whatever it is
but it's like
no you just sound like a loser for don't
play your own people
back in back in the days I remember I
had some dude he was the only black emo
I knew I don't care about you listening
to that that
that music I don't care if you like
what's the worst thing I could say you
do whatever you want to do right but he
was trading his hair and put it like you
know the the emo look where you have
your hair over here I don't know dude I
don't care you know that [__] yeah
straighten your hair you picking my hope
that's your style but there was a lot of
resentment from
from his is his own people yeah you know
because his people was uh rejecting him
and stuff like that it was a lot of
bullying
um we receive a lot of bullying from
black people so she veered off another
thing he didn't like dancehall reggae uh
hip-hop none of that so he went to that
stuff and he became that I think most of
this stuff comes from childhood I
remember even for me for a long time my
mom kept trying to do these like
arranged marriages with other Ethiopian
girls and I refuse to take Ethiopian
girl just a spider
which is not a good thing and now older
age everything's chill but you know
sometimes it's you're not thinking it's
cool sometimes it's being forced on you
you know some people will not want to
addict you from their own cultures
because their parents try to force it on
them so hard it's kind of like religion
you know if you were to let the kid find
it on their own or in their own time
they would have grown but because
parents made such a you know effort to
like shut you in and you're gonna take
this you're gonna love this and then you
reject it even harder because of how it
was pushed on you you know so most of
the stuff I think comes from if you
actually take time to dissect and
re-look at it just comes from your
childhood experience with either your
culture or whatever the the topic is so
anything else nah let us know what you
guys think